I don't know who to I don't know who to
cheer for I like both I just want a good
fight I don't want Tony get starched in
the 30 seconds and Dave goin's like all
that work my heart is with Tony Ferguson
me too my brain's with Patty and I I
love both these guys now here's the
thing I think if Tony wins he fights
Conor McGregor next uh
uh let Conor ever gonna [__] fight
again yeah yeah he'll fight Chandler
this uh well next year why is Conor
fighting he he got he's over worth over
over 100 million why would he fight
here's the problem though you train with
David gogins you go through this hell
camp this is only a 15-minute fight it
was five rounds then yeah Daddy that
fourth and fifth I feel like Ferguson's
always had that gas tank though not that
David goin's gassy how old is Ferguson
38 and how was Patty Pat's
12 he's young he's young super 20 like
20 what yeah he must be 20's 39 damn Dam
wa [__] that is's 28 so 28 okay 39 is
tough bro I'm 40 right now you 40 40 you
young as [__] and you got all that gray
all on your face well I used Just For
Men the other day you didn't use enough
I know well I look ridiculous I look
like Tom cic fores see you married so
you don't care no more that's what
happen when you get married yeah no no I
I I did die um and it it was a disaster
I looked horrible damn just quit being
cheap go to the barber shop you rich bro
go to get you a bobber and come to your
house or come here whatever twice a week
die yeah die and line you up I got a
barber that lives close up here really
not too far away he's the best next dude
no he
black you can do it I don't know if
that's F they dieet why not man you want
to go to a black barber bro yeah yeah
they are the best with Fades and [__]
even though I had long
hair they good beard too feel like it's
a bad match have you ever used Just For
Men no now how old are you 34 I almost
forgot damn you're 34 you're young
though just for a man it has to be a
joke everybody looks like DJ khed when
you put that [__] on I looked horrible I
look good with J for man it running out
right now you so black though that's
that's what she That's Just For Men yeah
yeah Y and when you in a thong you got
robbed you got be [__] up I was in a
thong bro hey it's all good D 200k
happens hey hey I'm not telling you [__]
what were you wearing what were you
wearing I had all my clothes on she was
a stripper and gunpoint no he was too
drunk I was too drunk and I and I passed
out she stole my whole luggage that I've
heard of this happening with dudes with
Rolex and stuff but at least 200k though
yeah man I had AP and some other jewelry
that hurts my soul man my PR boots God
damn what she GNA do with those damn
they really this I had my Bellator
jacket the heavyweight tournament jacket
damn that's Irreplaceable Irreplaceable
P right now Patty got hit though he's
getting hit yeah he's getting hit Bunch
the the problem is is Tony as long as he
do get knocked out he'll he'll wore this
out and have the stand on for I don't
know if Patty does but this is a no win
for Patty because you beat Tony goes
yeah he's lost seven out of the last
eight who gives a [__] you lose to him
it's you know it's G get tough for him
but I do think Tony fights Conor if he
wins his fight which is what I want for
Tony because you want a guy to make a
ton of money and be able to ride off in
the sunset yeah you don't want to see
him lose to Patty pay on the oh that's
[__] first he need to keep them hands up
now does he he he needs to I I would
mind him wrestling a little more I don't
know if those knees are still working
but he's not trying to wrestle clearly
that boy can wrestle how is B on how is
B on the ground really good that's it
that's his strongest his striking is
very low level for the at this level in
lightweight division but his grappling
is high level that's why that's probably
why Fergy don't want to take him down
but Fergie's nasty down there in the
transitions the DAR is an
anicas oh oh oh oh in trouble oh he's in
trouble that's that's it David goin's
walking in the locker room right
now wait wait wait wait he's still in
he's still he's still in it he's still
in it you got to block those you got to
block those he needs to go for [__] you
got to block those no no Tony you got to
you got to block those Tony's nice on
his back with the elbows o oh ride it
out 30 seconds 30 seconds come on DAV
Goin be so mad if you only fight for
five minutes come
on got the oh come on you gotta block
don't flatten out let I'd rather you
gotta block those referee you gotta
block those grab them
up 20 seconds brother a man he's still
good he he go to your back and survive
there you go he's good with his defense
there there you go go turn into him turn
turn turn
uh I like Tony in the guard there
[__] seconds 4 seconds as long as he get
knocked down 30 seconds we good you see
that Tony's nose bleeding like a faucet
oh man [__] man yeah 10 10 round where I
come from David Goin is so mad right now
I wish we could hear what the [__] Dave
is going to say oh what's going through
I'd love to hear what's going through
his mind he's not even in the corner
he's not giving technical things oh he's
not he's right there he's right there on
the back look at look at him uh oh [__]
what is he saying like let me I'm a lip
reader okay you got it damn we got Trump
Kid Rock and Mario Lopez in the back let
me read his lips what he saying he's not
saying nothing yet
he said get your thumb out your ass he
stupid said take it take it to him
F I'm so curious what David's saying
right now yeah he's not saying much
right now let me see he's he's letting
the coaches give him some technique then
he's just gonna maybe he has like code
words I bet he talks and code now put it
together get in this fight he's going
say all right Tony it's time he said
[__] him it's that nacho Madness like
talking code you know
nacho Madness na who knows all WatchON
watch Tony F come out be a new man now
you know that cardio's there you got all
those ticktockers in the back he's going
to get knock he's going to get knocked
out though he F it's going to be bad
[__] oh he's almost he almost failed
tripping on the monster but this how it
goes man 39 you're fighting some young
line Scout are at that man his Corner
are tell them keep their hand up there
you go keep it up
there that kick is tough on the
knees damn dude Tony's tough because his
style is so athletic and he needs all
the mobility and then when the age
catches up to you that that's the first
thing to go he on Orthodox oh yeah he's
on orod as
hell does Patty get tired cuz he looks a
little wind he looks a little wind right
now yeah he he's not Tony like Tony will
keep going no I like Tony from the guard
he's nicer with the elbows he got that
Eddie Bravo guard here that 10th Planet
guard he's nicer with rubber guard the
Els really good withed Kevin Lee from
his back with triangle eled him first so
I actually like it better down here him
the feet that was about 10 years ago D
no not 10 but probably probably five
yeah [__]
man so is it is it like an age really
where you're just like all right this is
it big time there's some freaks like
Randy Couture Brock Lesnar but in
general or Rampage but in general [__] I
aged overnight just one day hit you I
think I think so just one day is just
what did you notice most different how
how old are you Rampage I'm
45 like is it like just your endurance
the first thing I noticed about my age
is that my nuts got shriveled up like
more wrink that could have been the trt
cuz mine got super small I I haven't
done trt in a long time though oh [__]
oh yeah that your boy has you vegan and
no test no I ain't no vegan [__]
steroids at all you done steroids before
no that guy doesn't do Ser I was talking
about your guy oh he he didn't we're not
talking about me wa
W BR we're not talking about this on
Bradley wait a [__] minute dude hold
the [__]
on oh it's so funny man yeah there's
just certain age where you get like I
but what goes first what went first for
you like my
hamstrings your hamstrings just popped I
was sprinting against my buddy and both
just popped I was like oh I'm 40 I think
your speed goes first but it's it's not
on that I think it's like your uh your
coordination of something you see how he
moving and stuff like that yeah you're a
little you just get stiff like your
joints aren't as mobile and then um but
heavyweights can fight longer because
they're not they don't rely on their
movement as much as like a 155 like Tony
so heavyweights that you can they last a
lot they're older so they reach their
Prime later the lightweights and like
even below that the feather weights and
you know that [__] that it man
athleticism bro dude okay
yeah it's like why wide receiv receiver
in the NFL you better you got to be
pretty on your p's and
q's I had gray here my pebe I was like
dude I'm getting I'm a dad I got three
kids hair I did I did they got to be
embarrassing for yourself oh yeah it was
tough I haven't had that yet I haven't
had no Grays in my PB I got one gray in
my nostril though I hate that one that
bumps me out I've had that you know when
you getting really old when the hair
comes out the ears bro how do you not
know my manager Le sorry dude he has it
hanging out here I'm like bro
[__] manscape that [__] yeah manap
[__] the barber don't tell him godamn
his girl don't tell him and I hate when
your nose haars connect to your mustache
I hate that [__] that happens to him too
I'm like bro how do you not know this is
a [__] look I hate when I see when I'm
talking to men and they got long nose
hairs oh nothing worse I'm like how you
got a wife the the gray the gry nose
here is disgusting yeah I I put that
just for man on on my nuts on me nuts
did you really yeah dog wow yeah D how
many gray hairs did you have down there
I it's just that one man why you
hey no y talking yeah give that last
name she didn't want to take it no y'all
talking about me wearing thongs and [__]
when I said I got wrong you said thong I
got I got Rob I got robbed I was in a
thong no I said I got no I said I got
robbed at I got robbed and I was in a
thong I didn't say that I said I got
robbed at thong Point thong so I'm she
has a gun and you got a thong
on I thought I thought some Oscar De La
Hoya [__] dog C The Thong
Song
cuz it gets freaky man you never know
like you're so rock hard and she's like
just put this song on like whatever it
takes dog right like I just put these
panty hes on these boxing you think
that's what happened with him yeah and
he was like you was so bad he's like I
don't give a what what what do you want
to do high heels yeah you got a 13 you
don't think he was into that but why is
he posing for those P I've seen those
pitches I've seen them too what what how
many times have you seen them a handful
handful I saw it once and I I see I saw
once was getting I came back to him in a
week you know I'll check in monthly
it'll get brought up on a podcast once a
month if de Hoya had only fans would you
subscribe I check that [__] out the
Golden Boy on only fans doing some
little something strange for some change
would you do only fans no hell no my
dick too small I don't want everybody
seeing that no you ain't fooling nobody
[__] I ain't I ain't letting everybody
see all that hey I just did an interview
today cuz John singon um you know he
passed away and they doing like a
they're going to do a documentary story
about him and he reminded me Legend yeah
uh he the one who got me the 18 movie
originally a lot of people didn't know
that he I didn't know that yeah he was
going to be the director but he he
copped out because he didn't like the
direction that was going to go and um so
but he he wrote a movie for me and he
was going to make the movie damn who
John singon he like boys in the
hood Superman I thought you said John
Cena he loved him he loved me he the
reason why I got that role cuz I knew
what they was looking for right nobody
else knew everybody thought they were
looking for Mr T damn but John sington
told me exactly how had to go do the
audition everything right so he's going
to have this character named brick I'm
not going to tell you the whole story
cuz they might make it I don't know but
the one I turned the movie down I said
John I can't do I can't do that movie
cuz he wanted me to be doing some sex
scene smashing like this fat white girl
then oh you have a problem with that
yeah yeah and then come
Japanese stereotypical that's so but he
wanted me to open the door butt necked
everybody see my John can't bro a John C
movie I gotta be naked you do a John S
movie and you got to be naked I don't
give a [__] know what kind of I'd be on
for that my mom going to see that movie
100% I would have done it John SE that
is an honor I told him i' do if he if he
found a [__] double dude you're telling
me you wouldn't be Batman you wouldn't
be B Batman if they're like but there's
a scene where you're hooking up with
some fat white girls it wasn't that part
it wasn't that part that I turned down
was cuz he wanted me to open the door
but ass naked that one scene I said I
can't do that scene you could do it Dirk
digler style Mark Wahlberg where they
had a body double that long that's why I
told him he was like he said no he said
he going to be the whole thing he said
he don't want to do nobody for John sing
T I would have been like say less son I
would have done it you would have done
it now would you do Brokeback Mountain
[__] whoa what the [__] [__] was that oh
you don't want an Oscar I don't give a
[__] about an Oscar oh I'm gay cuz I
want an Oscar yeah you and I want act
like a gay cowboy yeah you won't Oscar
you want Oscar de la
ho you want to be the Golden Boy you
telling me you wouldn't do a broke R
Mountain to if you could guarantee an
Oscar no how much how much how much how
30 m no you crazy you you got to kiss a
man you got to kiss a man broke back
Mound dog it's the least of your
words that's the easy part yeah that's
the easy you be we shoot those scenes
Ferg is in his fight Ferg is in his
fight now yeah you get giltine here
maybe o
damn David Goin is my might be out of
the UFC after this he might man [__]
that y all some [__] huh he got soft
man yeah yeah but he knows how old here
comes that triangle he's trying to step
that triangle but Patty's well versed on
the ground it's just even on the ground
Tony's awkward so he might be able to
catch him with some he should keep keep
up with those elbows though he should
that's his thing right I'd rather have
Tony down here than on his feet on the
feet he's just too stiff there's David
look at him what is he saying read his
lips read his
lips how much does about MMA though not
a lot but he knows I get your ass in
shape move go
move get your [__] ass up and
move he does cuss a
lot having done this how much does
something outside even help not a lot
yeah yeah so whether it was Bruce Lee or
David Goggins there nothing especially
when you're ass who dudes on top get up
no [__] dude yeah come on get going yeah
yeah I'm trying dude yeah I figured that
was the thing the worst one when I was
fighting Gonzaga was third round I was
exhausted I was beating the exhausted
from beating the brakes off I was so
tired my coach yelled out 3 minutes and
45 seconds left I took I'm like God you
[__] my day up I'm so tired let me
know when there's a minute left what are
you doing exactly I hate that hated it
hated it oh I'll never tell me a minute
and 30 seconds that's all I want to know
3:45 Brandon keep keep it going I'm like
wow it it [__] you mentally so far away
from what are you doing yeah [__] with
you you never had MMA fight yet no no
one wants that smoke she he's been
asking she he been asking for it though
huh he in my way
[Laughter]
Class come on Fergie but you've kind of
backed off it right Bradley yeah you
still you were messing with it like I
mean I've been you get in shape too
you're you're lean right now you been
training MMA I've been training who you
training with I'm I'm
well David Goggins David gogins yeah
David Goin yeah I've been W I mean I was
talking about W and Logan but because I
feel like they're all going to go
towards that way yeah the the next
that's what it seems like the next
Edition for them would be MMA I'd assume
pfl or something so I've been doing some
some stuff here but you're so much
bigger than them still yeah but he's you
know obviously he's had more fights so
he's got that Advantage who who you
talking about Logan Logan Paul MMA yeah
he's a good wrestler yeah and he he's a
good Striker you don't want to fight him
yeah I do
Bradley Bradley 260 though I do you you
would have pick Brad Bradley over Logan
no I ain't never he he a never had a
fight true but I don't know what martial
art you know what martial art you know
ass kicking I mean I've trained Mor Thai
how long two years oh okay no no I know
two years bro two years of mu Tha can be
good enough to keep him from you know
what I'm saying getting knocked down in
the first 30 seconds and I trained you
jetsu how how long you train you just to
since it's about two years three years
that's that's good if he got the right
training that could be some big athletic
D like Bradley can dunk how's his cardio
a lot a lot better A lot better now yeah
that's why he that's why he's leaning up
yeah but I I you're almost too big and
strong I feel like it's such a liability
last round yeah last round that's the
last round it's been you know but like
he said he thinks he'd win so then he
should fight me why not You' you'd fight
Rampage no no no no Logan he thinks
Logan win so it's like it's easy for
Logan yeah true so that's a big fight
too I get I'll get a fight to Fergie
even though give that to Ferguson yeah
fer he he last it to the end give it to
the old man yeah get I don't feel like
that's what they're going to do no I
don't feel depending on what these
judges do there's going to be a lot of
people super upset what does what does
Ferguson do from here retires the UFC is
probably going to cut him after this
yeah but you can't lose eight fights and
they still keep you around I've never
heard anybody losing seven six seven in
a row usually four is the m five row
they can cut you what are we doing they
can cut you in the road legally in the
contract they can cut you at two like
he's done so much work there for Pat the
problem with this wasn't like a crazy
performance by Patty so again it's a no-
win situation for him all right you be a
guy who's lost one two three four five
six fights in a row okay so so you went
to decision with him so it's it's a no
win for him so what's what's what's next
to Ferg bear knuckle game bread probably
yeah I I could see bear knuckle offer
him a fight damn I know it's not good
it's not
good Legend too there's one time when
he's the best 155 on the planet him or
khabib they're supposed to fight then he
fell over CT at Fox blew his knee out
who ber fergon he was doing a press
thing and they were supposed to fight
like two weeks before blew his knee out
never returned the same Fu man that's
probably what you know when you get
older you get knee injury he tore
everything they said just he soone he
was walking out he has his glasses on
someone said Tony said what's up man
then turn boom tripped over a cord boom
blew every I Su that dud to call my name
I I would go back and I'll be pett like
that yeah to all yeah I'll go back and
be Petty like that